how are you Darrell I'm good rich I'm
sorry to hear about the back would you
do well I'm I tried to move something
heavy on Thanksgiving I bent at the
knees use my core I mean I didn't lift
it completely I just you know I lifted
it off the ground and then rolled it it
was a big circle a piece of cement and I
felt fine felt fine began to feel a
little bit funny in the back on Friday
and Saturday and Sunday morning get
ready for game day morning on on the
network try to put a sock on without
sitting down and boom I wound up on the
floor done Wow how's that story Darrell
were you were you locked in from
beginning to end and that's I was I
wasn't it's you know I've talked to
people who have gotten the back from a
sneeze it's amazing how the back can go
out so just put in the sock on or sneeze
can take a full grown man down to his
knees what about a flight to to Dallas
for Washington versus Dallas on NFL
Network to kick off week 13 how about
that yeah that's gonna be tough let's
place the Cowboys aside for a moment
what are your thoughts on what's going
on with the Giants in Eli Manning Darryl
I was really surprised to hear that we
actually had the San Francisco 49ers
ient gamin and that was kind of the the
first time that some of this discussion
popped up and it was about Davis Webb
and it was more about you know maybe the
potential for you know some some end of
the game opportunities for Davis Webb if
the if the score had gotten away from
the Giants it was not about Eli sitting
down and in Geno Smith coming in as the
starter and and even that week Ben
McAdoo said Eli Manning gives us the
best opportunity to win the game and I
don't know what's changed from the
preparation getting ready for the 49ers
game and so where we are this week where
all of a sudden Geno Smith gives the
Giants the best opportunity to win the
game so I was surprised I was
disappointed I know Eli has always said
it's not about the streak but I had a
streak going and when it ended it was it
was really disappointing to me that this
is disappointing in my mind for Eli just
everything that he's done a member and
o-7 him fighting to get on the field a
couple of times with that shoulder
injury you know he's been a warrior and
the biggest ability a quarterback and
bring to a team is availability and he's
been awesome he's been an Iron Man and I
just felt he needed to be treated with
with more respect if this was the
decision you were going to make in the
direction you were going to go
when you chatted with mackadoo when
you've been around him okay the I forget
who was on our show Brockman recently
who said some are there are some some
lieutenants and then there are generals
good who said that one of our football
related guests that have been on
recently at any rate that that
essentially that some coordinators
aren't intended to be head coaches what
vibe do you get off of McAdoo when you
meet with him Darryl I would agree with
that assessment I haven't been around
been enough I think he's grown from last
year to this year and especially since
the time we had him when he was just the
offensive coordinator with the Giants
under Tom Coughlin so there has been
growth but but I know exactly what what
your guest was saying you know I've been
around coaches where they can be great
coordinators but they're not going to be
a good head coach they can be great
position coaches and maybe not a good
coordinator so you know not to say that
they've they've reached their plateau
but it's just they've got to grow
they've got a you know they've got to
add more to the resume that they're
going to present and you can tell that
right away with leadership is one of the
big things there's so much that goes
into being a head coach you know the way
you handle the press and that was one of
the things that I think started this
whole thing it seemed to me that Ben
McAdoo was backed into a corner by a
question after that Rams game where he
opened the door to say that every player
every position was going to be evaluated
this week including the quarterback
position and that's kind of the first
time I'd heard that dialogue and
probably the first the first thing that
got us to the point where we're at now
with Eli not starting now yeah I know
that and and and at that time after that
very press conference Darryl I mean I I
said I don't know what McAdoo is
thinking because the the ownership is
never gonna let been McAdoo script the
end of Eli Manning's Giants career and
yet here we are and you know there's
there's no way that what was going on in
Dallas last year for instance with dak
and Romo that Jerry Jones wasn't
involved with every single second of
that decision right moose yeah exactly
exactly you know everybody's involved
with that you know Jason Garrett's gonna
be a part of it you know Jerry Jones
Steven Jones you know Wilma clay you
know everybody you know even Romo Ramos
going to be a part of that decision as
well so yeah this this is not something
that
that been mcadoo was going to do by
himself you know you know John Mayer a
Steve Tisch you're gonna be a part of it
you know every there's gonna be a number
of people that are gonna decide this and
and you know it's you know I have to
listen to your interview with Mike
Francesa to find out because he's going
to know more and one of the great things
I've heard today do when all this this
discussion on this topic is you know
David deal is right there at the Giants
you know training facility and and he
walked out to get coffee you know
earlier this morning during a break and
he goes I walk out and who are the two
people I see I see Eli Manning helping
Davis Webb with the game plan and that
just you know there's just another you
know little card to this whole decision
you know you know who does out I mean
how great of a guy is Eli Manning you
know here he is going through one of the
most difficult weeks of his life and his
focus is on helping the guy who could be
backing up the guy that took his
position get ready for the game but he's
not even gonna be active it doesn't seem
like apparently Eli's the second that's
the thing too it's just that if you make
this decision
start the kid not not the veteran that's
had a shot for the team that you share
the building with that that that your
giant fan base has nothing but disdain
for right and then and then then start
that guy now Eli's the backup and
putting your butt in his ear make him
stand on the sidelines if Ben McAdoo
really wants to know what he has in Geno
Smith I'm sure there's there's tens of
thousands of Giants fans he could call
the Jets too would be very vocal on that
Darryl moose Johnson and we'll talk
about Liberty tax in a second how do you
see the final five weeks of the cowboy
season playing out moose I don't know I
don't know gosh the last three weeks
have been tough you know I'd land was
probably playing their best football
when they ran into them obviously the
Eagles are the Eagles right now they're
playing as well as they have at any
point during the season and the Chargers
we had the charges against the bills the
Sunday before Thanksgiving and and and I
told the people in Dallas I said you
better watch this team I think they
figured some stuff out last Sunday and
Phillip Rivers had just an incredible
day so they're catching teams when
they're getting hot but but I liked your
point right before I came on
you know the Redskins seem to be a more
complete team right now even with all
the injuries that
had they seemed to be in a better
position to play a 60-minute game in a
certain style to get a victory tomorrow
night against Dallas and and I don't
know what's going to happen I mean at
least you have the Giants in that
portion of the schedule you got the
Raiders who are struggling
you've got Philadelphia which could be a
throwaway game the last game of the
regular season so I really think
tomorrow night is pivotal you know if
they're if they can win and get to two
to six and six you know who knows down
the stretch but if they lose tomorrow
night I think you kind of map out
scenarios go on the rest of the way and
it's it's all for naught it doesn't mean
anything well I guess it means nothing
anyway down because even if the Cowboys
win on Thursday night they've got a take
on Geno Smith the following week look
out already have a start under his belt
and honestly I make sense what what are
you doing with the wood Liberty tax
loose what are you doing with that we're
just trying to let people know the tax
season is right around the corner we're
trying to get everybody to be a little
bit more proactive this year you know we
want you to get a game plan put together
so we're asking you know everybody to to
kind of go to Liberty tax calm they've
got the tools there you can access the
tools yourself if you want to do your
own game plan but in situations like
these I'd rather defer to it to a
certified tax planner and you can also
find the locations near you in your
community at Liberty tax calm you can
walk in have them help you out with this
because there's a lot of stuff going on
and and there's even something that
happened last year where you know thirty
million people can expect their tax
refund to be held up by the IRR by the
IRS until at least the end of February
you know Liberty tax is going to help
you get that money back heavily access
thirty two hundred and fifty dollars as
early as January second so there's
there's some stuff that's going on is
Washington tries to rework all this
where I don't know if it's smart for for
us to do our taxes of ourselves anymore
so Liberty taxes is is asking you to
come out let's get a plan put together
let's get you ready for tax season and
let's make sure we do the best job we
possibly can through this year
Liberty tax calm and so um where are you
going this week what game generously we
have the Rams at the Arizona Cardinals
so it's a bone that's one moose for both
teams right here at Arizona nice victory
last week
against Jacksonville so you know they're
kind of back in the fray what are they
gonna be so yeah this is exciting and I
want to see I want to see if I was
impressed by the Rams bouncing back from
Minnesota against a team as good as New
Orleans even though they were at home
you know New Orleans is one of those
those hot teams in the NFL III want to
see now if they can sustain that against
somebody they should be able to beat I
mean they just destroyed Arizona in
London but you know this is a game that
they should win how do they handle
success everybody I think adversity is a
little bit easier to handle I want to
see how the Rams handle success that'll
be great I love that building to that
University of Phoenix Stadium it's a
great yes to watch a game we would rate
their ability we were just there a few
weeks ago and like I said I mean with
the Seahawks right on the Rams tail and
then the Rams play the Eagles the
Vikings play this week the Falcons would
then take on the Saints and one Thursday
from tomorrow and then the Vikings take
on the Panthers that week after the
Panthers take on the the Saints this
week it's just awesome
this thing is really just on fire right
now yeah link down the stretch is gonna
be fun to watch Atlanta Atlanta has got
a bear of a schedule though they do they
do
hey moose appreciate the time Thanks are
you gonna be in the Jones Mahal tomorrow
night will I see you there for that game
or not yeah yeah
I am actually going to be out there a
little bit early I will I will track you
down see how you're doing I'll bring you
a heating pad to put on your back free I
appreciate it moves thanks brother
you got a ready thank you that's down
moose Johnston the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience